I want to match what you're doing as
best I can to try and create a
homeostasis if you will we're in this it
looks like something from inception yeah
anyone who's just tuning in doesn't know
what's happening we look like two two
old druids in a sauna together
beautifully cocooned hostages of
misfortune is how I would describe this
Conan Russell I have to be honest with
you it's hard for me not to go to a
sensual place in it's as if I were lying
alone with you in a bed in the
countryside outside London so naturally
when's mine starts to wander one starts
to imagine well this is what it would be
like to be lying in bed with Russell
Brand we would have fantastic pillow
talk you and I I mean the conjugation
itself I think would be possibly
repulsive but after we've got through
that ordeal my god what were you
thinking that first of all you're
correct
whatever we managed to do together
physically it would not go well awkward
and to be a lot of apologies afterwards
we're very limited I've got long limbs
you brown limbs there would be elbows
and knees cracking about we'd be like
two lab skeletons that were thrown down
a hill together that's what it would be
it'd sound like if we went out but
Meccano with with ham just sprinkled in
hair yeah you know I'm happy to see but
it looks like you're enjoying your
existence as the docile connected
husband father yes is this correct I
enjoyed being sort of a famous person
for a while and I enjoyed the excitement
and approval and a short-lived
accolades etc but I feel I'm looking for
something more and only think part of
the arre evaluation that will take place
automatically as a result of these
extraordinary conditions dear Conan my
sweet gentle lover my strawberry strewn
one demand my you impish giant great
language creature you living sparkling
Emerald River people might be tempted to
put aside their constructions to which
they have been bound and investigate
different ways of living
isn't that a possibility I think it's a
possibility yeah well now I feel like
I'm straddling you yeah oh yes yes this
would be your view if you were
straddling me right now this would be
the view that you would have you look
startled well I think I would be
startled in that situation you know I
write to awaken and Russell Brand was
travelling me I wouldn't do it while
you're unconscious the hope you'd be
participating in the entire narrative up
to the point of the straddling I'd like
to feel your hands upon my hips your
breath upon my brow well I promise I
promise that if this ever is to happen
I'll be fully conscious thank you I'd
like to make the the same pledge I feel
like I might walk around a little bit if
I may I might go through several
lighting conditions we're probably going
to wrap this up soon it's been
absolutely what I would imagine that you
will I mean once we've you know sort of
played out a scenario where we were
strapped I move past my kids rooms and
want to like talk through the straddling
scenario where is they really left for
us to go murderer
you look like an intruder in your own
home yes Conan I feel like an intruder
in my own home a refugee
everyone well very good thank you yeah
with we passed the time with craft
activities is that the most English
thing you've ever seen there's a hound
ordinated with yours personal
pigmentation we call that a dog we don't
call it a hound Russell I want to make
sure I get this out download under the
skin is terrific podcasts available
we're from luminary media Russell I
can't wait to see you in the flesh
because we have opened a lot of
possibilities let's put it that way
we certainly a cultural has been opened
and I just hope to god we can shut it
Russell Brand absolute delight seriously
thank you very much for doing it be well
thank you for being here and please
apologize to your wife seeing my face at
any time of day when not expected is
horrifying
imagine when she gets the context and
the straddling stuff amines the poor
woman all right take care Russell CMA